[Musique]
bfm politique comme chaque dimanche en
compagnie des débits chevrillon pour bfm
business bonjour edwige je rappelle
d'ailleurs que nous pouvons être vu et
écouté sur bfm business tv radio le
parisien est avec david do cambon gentil
notre invité donc maire de pau haut
commissaire au plan président du modem
bonjour françois bayrou dont je
bienvenue dans cette émission je
voudrais commencer avec cette conférence
de presse du procureur antiterroriste
nous venons la suivre en direct sur
bfmtv suite à l'attaqué terroriste de
rambouillet on a appris quelques
éléments sur le parcours du terroriste
notamment qu'il avait eu des troubles
psychologiques qui n'ont pas donné lieu
pour autant on in internement n'y a de
la médication on a appris également que
son profil s'était radicalisé sur
internet et que l'expression de sa
radicalisation étaient visibles gérald
darmanin va présenter un nouveau texte
mercredi prochain en conseil des
ministres en gros la prorogation de
mesures de 2015 2017
est ce que cette nature selon joue à
lutter contre ce type de profil pour
éviter ce type de drame
la première chose qu'il faut avoir
l'esprit c'est que c'est extrêmement
difficile
voilà une voilà un personnage qui
n'était repéré par personne qu'ils
n'avaient aucune trace sur son casier
judiciaire dont la radicalisation date
de quelques semaines à peine qui n'a pas
d'armes d'autres armes et la sq qu'un
couteau c'est extrêmement difficile mais
le gouvernement a raison d'essayer de
monter le niveau d'alerté de précaution
et ce niveau d'alerté de précaution il
devrait être partagée par tout le monde
y compris dans l'univers médical on a vu
qu'il avait consulté le je pense que les
temps que nous vivons exige que nous
soyons en alerte tous mes petons s'était
pas seulement les services d'ordre de
sécurité de justice de tous d'accord sur
la durée françois bayrou alerte maximum
sur la durée est ce que c'est bien ça
sert chaque à tan tan dis ça si vous
croyez que ça va s'arrêter moi je suis
comme vous savez peu partisan des mots
et partisan des actes la répétition des
mots c'est vrai que d'une certaine
manière c'est ça ça donne à tout le
monde l'impression d'une espèce
d'impuissance et partisan d acte
partisan de la vigilance partisans de l'
alerte maximale pas oublier qu'un
certain nombre de dispositions que le
gouvernement avait présenté et fait
adopter ont été annulées par des
décisions du conseil constitutionnel
je pense que le gouvernement a à
l'esprit de monter ce niveau de
vigilance
opéra suffisamment efficace françois
bayrou parce que là on pourrait se dire
peut-on accepter en 2025 un homme qui
prétendait faisceau concordant comme ça
ne soit pas repérer les faisceau
concordant encore une fois ça veut dire
surveillance sur internet et vous savez
les boucles et levée de boucliers que la
surveillance sur cinq sur internet
provoque
je pense cependant que c'est nécessaire
si on veut éviter des drames de cet
ordre mais vous avez vu à quel point la
polémique est forte sur ces sujets et
donc que le gouvernement veuille
constamment élevé le niveau de vigilance
est vrai je ne crois pas qu'il s'agit
d'une atteinte aux libertés
pour ma part je crois que c'est une
sécurité qui est offerte à tous les
concitoyens que nous sommes et donc je
pense que le gouvernement a raison
juste une attaque personnelle il ya une
résonance particulière chez vous
avec cette attaque on va rappeler qui
est le responsable d'un centre d'accueil
de réfugiés qui a été poignardé à pau
1,7 au mois de février
poignardé et d'autres faits que nous
évoquerons peut-être dans la suite de
l'émission qui ont eu lieu à pau tout
savoir de la famille très proche
est ce casque à votre avis pour vraiment
il faut vous y at il un lien entre
l'immigration clandestine et la menace
terroriste via un lien entre le choc que
représente en effet l'immigration le les
déracinements d'un certain nombre de
personnages fragiles
bien sûr ce sont ces ça ajoute au risque
mais le l'immigration le le nombre de
déclarations de ceux qui quand il était
au pouvoir n'ont rien fait sur le sujet
est impressionnant il ya ceux qui n'ont
jamais exercé le pouvoir marine le pen
au niveau national en tout cas marine le
pen qui aucun niveau cas aucun avec un
niveau sur un plan exécutif
en tout cas elle partage le pouvoir
législatif on peut être d'accord là
dessus elle considère que ces drames
valide au fond les thèses qu'elle défend
depuis depuis des années elle explique
que avec elle les clandestins seraient
tous renvoyés chez eux et ainsi la
menace terroriste diminuerait que lui
répondez-vous françois bayrou pas vous
savez exactement à quelle aune il faut
juger ces déclarations et les français
le font parfaitement bien qu'amd et on
demande aux français dans toutes les
enquêtes
est ce que quelqu'un d'autre ferait
mieux sur ces sujets que le gouvernement
actuel
la réponse unanime presque unanime 80%
c'est non donc le chacun joue son jeu
vous voyez bien qu'il ya des polémiques
des oppositions de tout ceci et est un
peu secondaire
tous ceux qui nous écoutent sont
absolument habitué à ses déclarations
dans le je pense qu'il ya qui a peu de
gouvernements qui ont pris enfin dont
les dons les paroles sur ce sujet se
soit transformé en actes autant que ces
dernières années est ce que ça suffit
non ça ne suffit jamais le portent nos
deux secondes lorsque la menace remonte
la de la protection la précaution se
trouve toujours mises au défi
eh bien il faut le relever moi je crois
que le gouvernement le fait le jeune je
ne dis pas qu'ils fassent tous bien je
n'ai jamais vu de gouvernement qu'il
fasse tout bien et vous non plus vous
êtes des observateurs attentifs dans
toute la durée de l'histoire on n'a
jamais vu ça pourquoi parce que c'est
exactement la guerre perpétuelle entre
la menace et la défense le porte parole
n'a vraiment que vous évoquez dit ce
matin dans le journal parisien dans nos
colonnes il dit à chaque attentat
il y à ses victimes ses souffrances et
ses vautours
oui vous êtes d'accord avec sa roue et
est-ce que grand café vous aussi moi je
n'ai cirque indéfinissable de sentiments
exprimés sur ce plateau
avez vous un intuiti personae que fort
disait en latin personnellement je parle
d'eux
tous les observateurs savent que c'est
vrai et tous les français qui nous
écoutent savent que c'est vrai chaque
fois qu'il y à un événement il ya
exploitation de l'événement il ya une
question qui revient un peu
systématiquement et ce qu'il faut à
votre avis françois bayrou est ce qu'il
faut revenir sur le regroupement
familial
est-ce que c'est peut-être ce qui a
forcé développer l'immigration en france
et comment faire pour que pierre et
mohammed puissent être dans la même
école renforcer la mixité sociale
évidemment je fais allusion au
témoignage de cette jeune femme face à
emmanuel macron alors le regroupement
familial d'abord il est moins facile
qu'on ne croit à feu il ya ya
des précautions qui ont été élevés
contre tout ça c'est une affaire qui
date des années 70
jacques chirac et des années soixante
dix sept personnes depuis des années 70
n'a pris de mesures décisives sur ce
sujet là donc moi je fais très attention
vous savez bien à ce qu'on appelle les
yaka et les faucons 1
donc ça c'est ça c'est le premier le
premier point en personne ne nie que
toutes les situations de cet ordre sont
des situations qui augmente le risque et
personne ne nie qu'il faudrait
intervenir le plus tôt possible dans le
drame que nous avons vécu à pau et que
vous rappeliez c'est à dire l'animateur
d'une de ces associations qui viennent
en aide aux réfugiés aux sans papiers
qui essaie de les aider a été poignardé
par l'un d'eux ce qui relevait de
l'association et dans ce drame là on
voit bien que oui il y avait des signes
d' alerte préalable mais que les
décisions de justice n'avait pas été
appliquée parce que c'est la mixité
sociale sur la mixité sociale en voit
bien quelle fin aujourd'hui elle
n'existe quasiment plus malgré les
décisions qui ont été prises
malgré les logements sociaux on voit
bien que ça n'existe plus sûrs en ce
moment oui enfin dire que ça n'existe
plus
c'est un peu rapide j'ai entendu cette
déclaration on fils a jamais rencontré
un enfant qui s'appelait pierre il ya
beaucoup moins d'enfants qui s'appelle
pierre aujourd'hui y compris dans les
milieux n'est plus les plus
enraciné parce que il ya des vagues sur
les prénoms comme ça pas sûr que je
patiente la déclaration s'appliquait à
l'occurrence et prennent en pierre en
soit bel et bien je vais vous dire le
fond de ce que je pense s'il vous plaît
il ya un certain nombre de gens dont je
suis qui considère que e on ne doit pas
toujours être ramené à ces questions
d'origine de religion de couleur de peau
de deux communautés à laquelle on
appartient de il ya un certain nombre de
gens dont je suis qui ont envie qu'on
puisse aussi considérer les gens avec
d'autres sur d'autres éléments que ces
éléments qui consiste à tout ramener à
la communauté à laquelle on appartient à
la religion à laquelle on se rattache
on a envie d'être dans la situation on
regarde les ans pour les femmes les
hommes les enfants pour d'autres raisons
que celles là on a le droit de dépasser
ça l'espèce de mouvement perpétuel qui
consiste à tout ramener à auneau sion de
race les racisées les racialisée ou à la
couleur de la peau plus ou moins 2,2 à
au choix religieux qui souvent nous
seront imposés par par la famille par la
tradition familiale
toutes ces questions là dans l'état où
notre pays se trouve et dans l'état où
le monde se trouve elle compte elle
existe mais je suis pour qu'on arrête
d'en faire une autre message c'est nos
gouvernements session c'est au
gouvernement elle a dit travailler
françois bayrou est justement
justement je voulais rebondir cette
question d'edwige vous connaissez cette
théorie développée par gilles kepel du
terrorisme d'ambiance dont l' attaque de
rambouillet
this i -p c'est à dire si ces
terroristes qui se sont tout en bas du
spectre ou qui sont hors de spec qui ne
dépendent pas d'organisation il explique
aussi que les moyens de lutte de
détection ne sont pas suffisants qu'il
faut du culturel de l'associatif de
l'éducatif
ça participe de ce que vous dites à
l'instant très bien sur le diagnostic
dans les faits on fait comment non sur
le diagnostic pas très bien parce que ce
que le débat public alimente constamment
y compris sur vos chaînes de télévision
y compris sur les réseaux sociaux
ce que le débat public alimente c'est
l'exaspération de ses sujets alors je ne
dis pas qu'il n'existe pas vous savez
qui je suis et je suis quelqu'un qui est
croyant et laïque
en même temps j'ai toujours défendu les
deux peut-être on aura l'occasion d'en
parler mais c'est en même temps un homme
un père de famille qui a envie que ces
questions n'avaient glk pas noeud noeud
noeud ne soit pas la perpétuelle
obsession une femme ou un homme ce n'est
pas sa couleur de peau ce n'est pas sa
religion
ça n'est pas son origine ça n'est pas
son nom c'est quelque chose d'autre et
on a le droit d'avoir une approche
compréhensive
oui de france et versa vous nous dites
françois bayrou les universaliste ont
une bataille à mener
oui mais vous êtes en train de la perdre
non le vous savez ce que je pense que je
j'essaie de prouver dans toute ma vie on
ne perd que les batailles qu'on ne mène
pas alors il ya depuis en effet quelques
quelques années
il ya en effet des batailles qu'on ne
livre pas comme si c'était comment dire
la lutte du pot de fer contre le pot de
terre comme ceux qui voulaient ne pas
être prisonnier de ses obsessions était
par définition submergés par les vagues
qui se développe sur vos écrans parce
que ça joue un très grand rôle le monde
médiatique et le débat médiatique sur
ces sujets si vous prenez les débats que
vous organisez avec des experts les
contres experts les témoignages les deux
à toute heure du jour et de la nuit avec
des visages qui change
il ya deux débats il ya le sanitaire
enfin débattre est un temps et il ya ces
questions d'identité de race 2 2 vous
êtes vous êtes une chambre d'écho
c'est pas le reproche que je vous en
fait vous vous prenez tous tout ce qui
brûle
parce que c'est plus c'est plus
intéressant c'est votre métier
cependant considéré que je suis une
seconde le représentant de ces millions
et millions et millions de français qui
considèrent que c'est pas ça le sujet
principal rassurer au fonds seraient en
tout cas si le nom gardé à la régularité
oserait qu'il n'ya pas que les choses
qui brûle il ya aussi beaucoup de gens
ce que vous faites aujourd'hui qui
viennent parler du fond des sujets et ce
n'est pas parce qu'on n'en parle pas
qu'il n'existe pas vous êtes d'accord
avec ça mais oui mais mais vous avez
compris cette sensibilité que je
représente là ce ne sont pas des gens
qui disent ces sujets n'existe pas je
suis maire d'une ville il ya des
quartiers je sais bien les difficultés
je sais bien les incidents je sais bien
ce qui se passe à certains moments très
bien et puis des drames vous avez évoqué
que nous n'avons vécu quelques uns mais
cependant il n'est pas possible que ces
sujets envahissent les écrans
au point que on soit obligé de se
référer à la couleur à la race au prénom
à l'origine à la culture
alors qu'on a envie de dépasser sa
puissance alors les histoires de prénom
c'est très simple c'est là encore des
vagues j'ai toujours rêvé si j'avais eu
plusieurs vies qu'une de ses vies
auraient été de sociologues parce que
j'aurais essayé
liszt d'analyser ces affaires de france
est encore possible mais une
reconversion est encore pony dernier je
finis et finis je vous raconte les vies
ça met un peu de le les prénoms c'est
formidable parce que les parents la mère
qui attend le bus et s'interrogent avec
leurs proches pour choisir un prénom qui
soit original quand même temps qu'ils
soient chaleureux et bienveillant qui
disent quelque chose de la personnalité
et chacun se creuse la tête en direction
de cette originalité et même de ce
caractère unique du prénom et
choisissent tous le même en même temps
alors en scène un truc j'étais enfant
non mais pas mal de sujets dont nous
étonnons pas que les usa posé une
question sur un prénom il ya un prénom
c'est celui d'emmanuel emmanuel macron
est ce que il dit mardi
il nous dit mardi dans le figaro que
nous avons droit à une vie paisible
oui et vendredi cette fonctionnaire est
assassiné 7
cette conjonction est terrible pour le
président de la république est ce que
vous comprenez que nous allons devoir
vivre comme ça pendant des décennies
vous lutter contre l'alcool au volant et
le gouvernement dit à juste titre ça
n'est pas acceptable et trois jours
après vous avez un drame de précisément
liting savoir ce que la politique n'a
pas tous les pouvoirs sur la société
ça veut dire qu'il n'existe pas de
dirigeant dans quelques pays du monde
que ce soit regardez les états unis avec
les fusillades
il n'existe pas de dirigeants qu'ils
puissent décider de sa propre volonté
que tous les malheurs tous les drames
toutes les jolies toutes les dingueries
vont disparaît les décennies vous dit
françois bayrou
oui on la menace terroriste en france
des décennies ce depuis combien de temps
existe t-elle dit waouh des décennies
déjà 40 ans des décennies d'ailleurs car
1995 40 ans messieurs
métro saint michel mais accélère les
attentats antisémites combien 40 ans 50
ans bien sûr et avant les attentats de
l'oas et lui les attentats du fln contre
donc ça fait 60 ans et si on veut monter
on en trouverait probablement aussi
beaucoup on savait où sont inscrits dans
l'histoire
je vous suggère un autre prénom ya
marqué l'actualité
cette petite fille qui était enlevée par
sa mère les services sociaux lui avait
retiré
il estimait que sa maman représenter un
danger pour elle derrière l'enlèvement
il y à une mouvance dite complotistes
qui a organisé ça est un homme présenté
en je sais pas si on a raison le faire
ou pas d'ailleurs comme un gourou de ce
mouvement qui est un ancien du modem
vous l'avait exclu un de votre de votre
parti immédiatement
est ce que vous aviez été alertés par
ses prises de position est ce que ça
vous inquiétez à l'époque c'était un
déséquilibré errants et on a pris les
décisions qui s'imposaient pour qu' il
ne soit plus dans nos rangs quand quand
vous avez un parti politique il ya des
adhésions et vous n'êtes pas toujours
certain de l' équilibre des adhérents
mais malgré tout françois bayrou est ce
que ce qu'on peut this may visage
découvert est-ce que là aussi ça vous
inquiète
est ce que vous dites c'est un phénomène
qui est en train d'émerger bah c'est un
peu du même ordre que le terrorisme que
nous évoquions et la réponse est la même
si vous voulez lutter contre ça il faut
des moyens de lutter est un des moyens
c'est le contrôle d'internet ce qui fait
levée des boucliers
ce qui fait lever des mouvements de
protestation extrêmement puissant parce
qu'il ya une partie de la société qui
voudrait que l'internet soit un univers
sans contrôle et je n'appartiens pas à
cette partie de la société faut faire
attention à toutes les libertés
c'est cet équilibre là qu'est qui est
évidemment difficile à trouver mais qui
est vital des rassemblements sont
attendus cet après-midi hommage à sarah
halimi surtout critiques contre la
décision de la cour de cassation de ne
pas reconnaître son assassin responsable
de ses actes et ce en raison de son
importante consommation de cannabis la
juridiction a pourtant reconnu le
caractère antisémite de l'attak
je rappelle que avait également été
garde des sceaux est ce que vous
partagez la vie d'emmanuel macron il
faut changer la loi
je pense qu'il faut changer la loi et
même si vous me permettez de le dire je
pense qu'il faut la changer plus
profondément que ceux qui
et aujourd'hui envisagée alors je dis ce
qui est aujourd'hui envisagée comment
est il possible d'accepter que un
automobiliste ivre ou d'ailleurs ayant
pris du cannabis en même temps qu'ils
tuent une petite fille sur un passage
clouté serait un jour déclaré
irresponsable de ses actes
c'est purement et simplement la
supportable deuxièmement quelle
différence entre l'automobiliste pour
qu'ils l'alcoolémie est un facteur
aggravant mais voilà et puis ce crime
atroce et barbare
quelle différence pour moi aucune est
donc la différence qui s'était établi
par la jurisprudence sur ce sujet
tendant à déclarer irresponsable
quelqu'un qui sait qui a qui s'est
adonné à la drogue
on pourrait demain à voir des gens qui
s'adonnent la drogue pour être déclaré
irresponsable
donc de ce point de vue là il faut
changer la loi et moi je pense qu'on
peut qu'on doit aller beaucoup plus loin
comment parce que ce qui est à mon sens
profondément choquant sur ce sujet ça
n'est pas que quelqu'un soit déclarée
irresponsable parce que il est
déséquilibré fou comme on dit c'est que
ça se fasse sans procès parce que c'est
un manque de d'attention de respect pour
les victimes
il n'y a pas que les assassins que les
tueurs ou que les barbares à l'égard de
qui il faut avoir naturellement le
respect de la loi il ya les victimes
vous voudriez d'établir si quelqu'un il
faut nous avons eu je vais vous dire ce
que parce que ce que je pensais
nous avons eu en 2004 à pau vous
souvenez un histoire absolument atroce
dans un hôpital psychiatrique
un type qui est venu qui a tué et
décapité de personnel de l'hôpital
psychiatrique et il a été déclaré
irresponsable
donc il n'a jamais été jugé imaginez les
familles imaginez les enfants
marie de ses deux deux jeunes femmes
imaginées le ce que ça représente comme
comme déchirement intérieur et comme
sais pas quoi sentiment d'abandon de la
part de la société
moi je pense qu' il faudrait changer la
loi sur un point ça n'est pas que ce
type de personnalité ne doivent pas être
jugés
ils doivent être jugés et éventuellement
déclaré irresponsable à l'issue du
procès même s'ils doivent être jugés en
leur absence après tous attendaient ce
serait de la contumace il reviendrait à
des magistrats d'établir si quelqu'un
est malade
sur un plan mental alors que c'est la
responsabilité des psychiatres dans
notre pays bell de dans le cas qui nous
occupe signe aussi les experts si vous
avez suivi donc c'est les magistrats qui
ont dit les experts vont dans ce sens
oui mais nous donc une majorité
d'experts va dans ce bien sûr moi je
pense que ça devrait se faire à l'issue
d'un procès parce que les victimes
songez à la famille de sarah halimi le
pendant 40 minutes à les torturer roué
de coups et puis jeter par la fenêtre et
on leur dit il responsable c'est
également adopté videmment insupportable
mais en france on ne juge pas les fous
attendez c'est vous oui on dit on dit ce
genre de phrase en france on ne juge pas
et bien moi je considère que
l'irresponsabilité
elle doit être établi à l'issue d'un
procès qu'on le doit aux familles
donc tout le monde pour dire les choses
clairement tout le monde doit être jugé
kit être déclaré responsable à l'issue
du shopping quand il y à martres et
assassinats actes de torture et de
barbarie
ce sont des choses suffisamment grave
pour les victimes pour qu'on ne
considère pas qu'on peut exonérer
quelqu'un d'un procès alors je suis sans
doute minoritaires d'ailleurs vos
réactions non nous posons des questions
à nos questions pour comprendre
vous mais pas encore pour qu'on pourra
converser ce sont des sujets vraiment
très très important tout ce qui nous
occupe bien sûr mais cette cette
présomption de non jugement
à partir du moment où on reconnaît que
quelqu'un à son à son son jugement à la
folie ou altérés pour moi ça devrait
être prononcée à l'issue d'un procès et
jeudi on doit cela aux victimes alors
qu'un autre âme justice une autre
affaire dans laquelle il ya eu un procès
c'est la tacc de viry-châtillon des
policiers brûlé dans leurs voitures en
2016 cinq individus condamnés 6 à 18 ans
de réclusion
mais huit acquittement alors ça a
déclenché des propositions politiques
nous sommes dans une année
présidentielle
xavier bertrand considère qu'il faudrait
changer la constitution pour instaurer
une peine automatique d'un an de prison
pour toute personne jugée coupable d'un
geste d'une attaque contre quelqu'un qui
est dépositaire de dépositaire de
l'autorité publique
que pensez vous ancien garde des sceaux
de cette proposition le comme on dit
dans vos colonnes il écrit le concours
lépine des le concours vous savez c'est
ce concours pour des inventaires pour
des inventeurs on met là dedans on va
être là dedans pendant alors si on prend
les si on prenait des choses au pied de
la lettre
un an de prison c'est peu n'est ce pas
il n'y a pas eu un jugement inférieures
ou égales c'est combien entre 6 et 10
807 18 ans ceux qui ont été grandes
allées que vous voyez qu'il ya là
quelque chose d'un peu d'un peu
étrangement je demande que qu'on fasse
attention à la multiplication des
propositions mais j'ai zéro
les lycées sont en colère je sais ce que
c'est j'en ai fait les policiers sétois
juste les policiers en colère exercice
est laxiste
l'axis disait-il il estime aussi que ce
jugement cette décision de justice
encourage ce qui le souhaitent à s'en
prendre aux forces de l'anp moi
j'utilise pas des objectifs de cette
heure je vais vous dire ce que ce à quoi
je pense un policier une policière qui
est dedans
devant ce genre de situation qui mène
une enquête qui arrête quelqu'un et
qu'il retrouve dans la rue le lendemain
matin sans qu'il y ait eu sanction
simplement parce qu' un certain nombre
de mécanismes ont joué
il est exaspéré et je comprends cette
exaspération ça je comprends cette je
comprends cette cette incompréhension
comment ça se fait on se désarme nous
mêmes et donc de ce point de vue là il
ya des orientations à prendre il y en a
une qui est à prendre
il faut approfondir cette question de
bande 1 parce que le e
celui qui appartient à une bande et qui
voit sous ses yeux se dérouler ces faits
absolument ignoble ont cassé la vitre on
jette un cocktail molotov à l'intérieur
pour tuer des fonctionnaires de police
qui sont là elle ne doit pas d'être
acquitté ce que vont dire celui qui est
là qui assistent et qui ne fait rien
cela s'appelle un assistant personnes à
ranger ça s'appelle non-assistance à
personne en danger et donc le phénomène
de bande
dois je crois que c'est d'ailleurs la
loi être un facteur aggravant de la
situation semblait donc vous voyez que
prendre la question uniquement du point
de vue individuel alors il est vrai que
dans les principes de la loi il n'y a de
responsabilité que personnel c'est vrai
mais il ya des facteurs qui sont des
facteurs aggravants et le phénomène de
bande mérite une prise de conscience de
notre part à tous j'aurais que nous
avancions parlant de la crise sanitaire
les écoles vont rouvrir demain vous êtes
donc merde pour en responsabilité je le
rappelle pour un téléspectateur
maternelles crèches écoles primaires est
ce que vous êtes prêt et j'ai été
ministre de l'éducation en plus
est ce que pendant quatre ans est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à pau art accueillir les
enfants oui je pense que 8
vous voyez bien le débat l'on va si vous
voulez on va prendre un peu de recul sur
le débat pouvoir le pouvoir les
principes
moi je pense qu'on peut pas fermer un
pays on peut pas mettre un pays sous
cloche tout le temps de manière durable
et donc j'ai soutenu le l'orientation du
gouvernement disant essayons de
maintenir le plus possible au maximum la
vie et notamment la vie pour les enfants
et pour les jeunes les dégâts qui sont
faits il ya c'est dans un journal ce
matin le l'explosion des cas de
violences familiales de violence à
l'égard des ensembles violence à
l'intérieur des couples liés à cette
situation d'enfermement
c'est aussi un dégât collatéral et les
retards de langage parce que l'école ça
sert ça sert à ça que ça sert à apporter
le langage la sucette la sociabilité
l'enfermement
les êtres humains ne sont pas faits pour
être enfermés et mis en situation de
même très bien on a eu raison étrange on
a eu raison de suivre toutes les
précautions sanitaires possibles il y en
a un certain nombre qui sont à mes yeux
mal expliquée par exemple le fait qu' il
n'y a pas ou très peu ou presque pas de
contamination dé connaître au grand air
quand on est au grand air qui a les
distances nécessaires et si les
distances sont pas là canal masque il
n'y a pas de contamination
et donc j'ai j'ai plaidé depuis
longtemps pour qu'on rende le grand air
et donc oui nous sommes prêts à
accueillir les enfants dans les écoles
permet de le la la région de france qui
eut une des très petit nombre de régions
de france et kehl moins de contamination
s'avèrent aussi en même temps vous êtes
parents vous avez envie de mettre votre
enfant à l'école de vos enfants à
l'école parce que vous travaillez sera
compliqué de faire la classe et être en
même temps au télétravail et puis
l'autre côté vous allez mettre lundi aux
enfants à l'école
et puis vous savez qu'ils ont toutes les
chances de se faire contaminer donc de
vous contaminer cc c'est quand même une
situation complexe un choix cornélien
pourquoi d'huile chaude lyon pour un an
ferme et qui n'est pas d'école je plaide
pour une réponse
l'ama ma réponse à moi c'est que l'école
est indispensable à la vie
david à la vie des enfants à la vie des
familles et simplement à l'idée qu'un
pays ne se ne se ne s'enferme pas alors
justement parlons de libération mois de
mai ça met d'accord en mai fais ce qu'il
te plaît on n'y sera pas enfin c'est à
dire un peu mieux on lit que peut-être
votre département les pyrénées
atlantiques pourrait être département
test pour le déconfinement
territorialisée ce que vous avez ces
informations-là françois bayrou oui je
comprends c'est encore une fois nous
avons la chance d'être un des deux
départements français le moins atteints
par l'épidémie
on a pris beaucoup de précautions on a
beaucoup testé on a on vaccine enfin bon
mais on a la chance par la géographie et
puis peut-être par la qualité de l'air
en terre d'être d'être plus à l'abri que
d'autres oui je comprends très bien
qu'on ait une approche localiser
régionalisés oui nous sommes prêts à
l'affronter soyons en garde contre le
fait qu' il est tout d'un coup des
phénomène de vases communicants entre
les régions d enfin libérés ou en tout
cas pour lesquels on est ouvert la
possibilité un certain nombre de
possibilités et les autres salles sans
se sentir le vent chez vous t'es pas
sait pas on met un peu de décider de la
date c'est acté l'attendant roissy ce
matin jean castex
en déplacement au à l'aéroport paris
roissy pour mon réexpliqué les mesures
qui sont prises de contraintes pour des
gens qui rentreraient du brésil d'inde
il ya toute une liste de pays on a
l'impression qu'on a un train de retard
or je parle de train alors qu'on est à
l'aéroport mais vous m'en excuserez ont
l'impression que c'est trop tard on a
l'impression que ça me remet toujours
des jours et des jours avant de prendre
des décisions qui apparaissent relever
du bon sens
oui alors le
l'espèce de réquisitoire perpétuelle
contre les gouvernants nourrie par la
totalité des acteurs et observateurs
c'est un sport national je ne me livre
pas franc oui vous savez au nec ne
compte jamais fédérer
j'avais plaidé pour le report des
élections municipales au mois de mars
2020 j'ai pas eu gain de cause
j'ai plaidé pour le report des élections
du mois de juin est-ce que ça aussi ça
va faire des j'ai pas eu gain de cause
parce que tous les leaders de
l'opposition sans exception sont montés
au créneau en disant c'est une atteinte
démocratique insupportable en réalité
parce que ils pensent qu'ils vont avoir
un gain électoral
si c'est si les gens votent moins de
temps qu on en est là ce qui est pas peu
ce qui est inacceptable mais qui est
pour moi un signe de de retard
incroyable c'est qu'on est toujours pas
en france de vote par correspondance
on n'a toujours pas en france de votre
part internet
on n'a toujours pas en france de vote
par anticipation alors que tous les pays
qui nous entourent aux états unis il ya
100 millions de personnes qui ont voté
par correspondance
je trouve ce je trouve cette incapacité
assumé par les administrations et les
les grands les grands autorités
gouvernementales je trouve ça désolant
on vous interroge une maîtrise des
frontières vous répondez droit de vote
par correspondance on s'en est rendu
compte
juste vous vous le 6 mai les noms mais
maîtrise des frontières de l'est fronde
d'inde je suis bien placé pour le savoir
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de
possibilités de voyage france à zéro ce
qui pourrait aider les français à se
déplacer pour voter jude récit vous
parce que le 10 ans résidant philibert
entendez vous autres vous du brésil en
sentant j'annonce du brésil quoi de plus
normal que de fermer les frontières
quand on sait ce que le variant
brésilien provoque comme accident c'est
pas la faute des brésiliens le variant
c'est une mutation du virus
on en aura d'autres on n'est pas sorti
de cette opération au plan
j'ai produit note au mois d'octobre la
première et la seule jusqu'à maintenant
qui a été produite en europe dont le
thème était et sylvie russe durée on est
en octobre
tout le monde croyait que
fallait finir voilà donc la raison est
que oui il faut vacciner
et oui il faut être prudent et oui on a
raison quand on prend des mesures de
prudence
justement dans mo
je pique une question à david du camp si
vous êtes des fidèles de l'émission vous
savez c'est toutes les semaines sa
question récurrente mais qui fait encore
plus en ce moment sur la vaccination
il y à beaucoup d'endroits en france ce
n'est pas une un mot d'esprit il ya
beaucoup d'endroits en france qui ne
trouve pas preneur des doses qui ne
trouve pas preneur
j'interroge à un médecin généraliste
hier de mulhouse qui a jeté des doses
faute de personnes à vacciner
est-ce qu'il faut ouvrir la vaccination
à tous le monde plus largement dire aux
gens en tout jeune et il faut prioriser
et quand on a des problèmes de doses
supplémentaires
il faut les ouvrir à toutes les
générations bien entendu élagueurs
zeneca l'interview 55 ans pourrait donc
je vais vous dire c'est ce qui se fait
non mais astrazeneca ya des raisons
médicales mais au royaume uni par
exemple pour autant oui bah voilà donc
choisi de faire vacciner avec notre à
zenica
en france 1 0 non je me fais vacciner à
la date prévue par moderne d'accord et
juste sur l'astra pour combler ce pack à
30 ans comme au royaume uni posez la
question aux spécialistes haute autorité
de santé
mais d'un point de vue je vais à ses
relations sa politique intérieure sa
fréquence pour vous c'est tout ce que
vous avez dit de je répète comme vous
savez je défends la vaccination depuis
le 1er juillet bien sûr et je défends
même depuis le premier jour le passeport
vaccinale en tout cas un document un
certificat de vaccination pour qu'un
certain nombre d'activités puisse
rouvrir
je suis favorable à ce que chaque fois
qu'on a des doses excédentaires
il faut absolument qu'elle soit
prescrite est utilisé pour des
concitoyens ce que ça fait monter le
niveau de vaccination de la nation
avançons
parlons alors c'est un sujet que je sais
pas si c'est un sujet qui fasse david
mélé la proportionnelle je voudrais vous
demander tout simplement si on peut dire
à nos concitoyens que en juin 2022
ils ne voteront pas à la proportionnelle
pour les législatives
vous me demandez autrement dit si c'est
plié
voilà et bien pour moi ce n'est pas plus
je sais que ses papiers pour vous et
c'est très surprenant alors dit je suis
je suis peut-être un incorrigible
optimiste ou un combattant infatigable
quand il ya des sujets que je considère
comme vitaux vous voyez bien ce qui se
passe la rupture entre le sommet
prétendu se met en place deux de nos
institutions et la base mais c'est un
cet homme né pouvant table malheur
national
on devrait pas accepter ça pour quoi
parmi les causes ne dis pas que ce soit
la seule parmi les causes il ya une
cause évidente c'est que plus de la
moitié des français ne sont pas
représentés dans nos institutions
parce que simplement ils appartiennent à
des partis minoritaires et toute ma vie
j'ai plaidé pour que eux on ne considère
pas comme légitime que parce que vous
êtes minoritaires vous êtes exclu parce
qu'aujourd'hui les minoritaires ensemble
ils font la majorité
or tous les risques qu'on décrit
abondamment sur la proportionnelle
franchement si on regarde tous les pays
d'europe qui nous entoure en allemagne
c'est la proportionnelle intégrale le le
gouvernement de l'angola merkel est en
place depuis 16 ans
figurez vous le nombre de ceux qui ont
défilé chez nous depuis 16 ans 1
donc on dit c'est la stabilité d'un côté
mais votre compte vous êtes habile et
même j'irai plus loin il tient pas
parole au fond il tient parole mais
c'est pourquoi vous vous dites c'est
plié moi je dis ça n'est pas plus parce
qu'une parole a été donnée parce que pas
seulement parce qu'il faut à tout prix
qu'on rende de l'oxygène à notre vie
politique et je disais les risques
n'existent pas parce que chez nous nous
avons l'élection du président de la
république au suffrage universel et de
gaulle quand il a créé l'homme est
apprécié par les questions régime a dit
quelque chose
il a dit c'est le président de la
république qui formera le gouvernement
en tenant compte des nuances de
l'assemblée et de gaulle en 45 il a
choisi la proportionnelle parce qu'il
savait bien qu'il faut faire respirer un
pays et empêcher le monopole du pouvoir
alors j'ai quand même une question à
propos du modem parce qu'on sent qu'il
ya peu le traitement à l'occasion de ces
élections régionales et du foot mandat
au sein du modem lorsqu'on voit ce qui
se passe en île de france notamment en
ile de france vous avez des élus du
modem qui ont décidé de soutenir
d'apporter leur soutien à valérie
pécresse alors qu'il ya une liste la
république en marche qui était a tenu
par lançant martin et on voit bien qu'à
une alliance entre le modem et la
république en marche est ce que parce
qu'ils restent les mêmes dans les
statuts du modem est ce que vous allez
françois méro exclure les maires qui
soutiennent
valérie pécresse écoutez c'est très
simple j'ai pas l'habitude de me défiler
les décisions qui doivent être prises
seront prises mais vous avez dit des
élus qui soutiennent pas des élus cdh et
sortants qui ont participé à cette
majorité là et dans une région ou une
autre c'est comme ça aussi ça peut sont
des choses parfaitement compréhensible
mais le la force d'une d'un mouvement
politique c'est sa cohésion tant qu'il
sera un disque les deux cette cohésion
je suis le garant centre val de loire
marc fesneau ministre des relations avec
le parlement modem il est candidat il
est candidat pour prendre la région au
fond est ce que le modem
va sauver l'honneur de la majorité
danser dans ces élections régionales -
pas trop les candidats et les mêmes la
être dans des situations de deux nous
avons de vivre nous avons deux candidats
qui sont en première ligne marc feydeau
et geneviève darrieussecq en nouvelles
aquitaine tous deux membres du
gouvernement plus dur en nouvelles
aquitaine marmen web
la situation politique est pas tout à
fait la méchante mais mais mais marc
fesneau c'est quelqu'un de très bien et
c'est pas parce qu'il a l'étiquette du
modem c'est pas parce que il est
ministre
c'est parce que tous ceux qui le voient
et leur encontre savent que c'est
quelqu'un de bien et je trouve que qu'il
ressemble à cette région par son
équilibre et par un petit un petit
éclair d'humour ou d'ironie au coin des
yeux c'est une région qui n'aiment pas
être dupe de toutes les apparences de
tous les galons sur les épaules de tous
c'est une région qui qui aime bien les
galons savoir c'est fini tout ça c'est
la singularité 27 juin il est élu il
faut assumer ses responsabilités il est
battu au suffrage universel cinq
ministres vous en avez pas facile vous
parle non non vous en parlerais avec le
président de la république
transformation des cantons quand on va
au feu dans des situations difficiles
ben on mérite la considération toujours
au sujet de la campagne des élections
régionales
j'imagine que vous avez vu
la campagne d'affichage la campagne
visuelle d'europe écologie les verts en
ile de france
énorme polémique le parti met au même
niveau les chasseurs les fachos les
boumeurs vous êtes en bout un françois
bayrou sont les gens qui sont nés du
baby boom dans ces périodes entre 45 et
60 n'ont entre 45 et 75 m way 75e
on a élargi est ce que vous avez alors
la campagne c'est pour dire que en gros
ces gens là vont défendre leur intérêt
dont se déplacer pour voter et que si
vous êtes partisan de la défense de
l'écologie faut le faire pour faire
entendre votre voix aussi c'est la rider
énorme polémique quel est votre
sentiment c'est toujours la même
histoire celle que je décrivais il ya
une minute au début de cette émission
c'est que on ramène toujours les gens à
l'heure je disais couleur de peau
religion est là à leur âge à leurs
opinions
plus personne n'est regardé comme un
citoyen cette campagne elle dit on
regarde pas les gens comme des citoyens
on les regarde comme appartenant à une
catégorie une communauté et que c'est la
catégorie et la communauté qui font le
vote parce que vous avez plus de 50 ans
mettons ça veut dire que vous ferez
d'une certaine manière et c'est une
campagne qui dit quoi elle dit parce que
vous êtes jeune vous ne pouvez voter que
pour nous pour moi ça ne ressemble pas à
la démocratie au débat démocratique
comme on voudrait le vivre comprenait
aucun d'entre nous mais mais son genre
ni son sexe ni son âge ni son origine
on est tous des citoyens en train de se
faire de se former parfois on se casse
la figure
mais vous comprenez le vote c'est
considérer quelqu'un comme un
responsable individuellement
personnellement personnellement
responsables et personnellement en
conscience cc c'est une dérive une de
plus c'est pas la plus grave votre
élection présidentielle autre élection
c'est l'élection présidentielle c'est
dans ces dans quasiment un an jour pour
jour et on voit bien que les sondages il
va y remettre
le duel qu'on a connus par de la
précédente élection présidentielle
marine le pen face à emmanuel macron si
ce n'est que effectivement marine le pen
elle est encore plus haut dans les
sondages qu'elle ne l'était à lors de la
précédente élection présidentielle est
ce que quelque part c'est quand même un
échec pour les manuels macron il n'a pas
réussi à faire reculer le front national
et marine le pen eu le succès du
président de la république c'est qu'il
ya personne dans le champ démocratique
qui considère qu'il ya meilleur que lui
pour pour la période dans laquelle nous
sommes et pour les responsabilités
énormes dont on dira peut-être un mot
personne séquelles comme vous savez je
sais pas toujours tendre à l'égard des
responsables parce que je crois à des
choses profondes et et quand ils sont
pas au rendez vous ça je trouve que
c'est pas là à la hauteur lui il est en
pleine conscience
il est respecté de tous les dirigeants
du monde parfois dans des conflits
justifier le des confrontations qu'il a
eu avec trump avec poutine ce sont des
confrontations garde justifier sur les
questions européennes garde le cap
on parlait hors antenne du chevrillon du
nucléaire et j'ai largué pour le coq
l'as olemps pour l'instant j'en ai plein
et bien je ne le crois pas c'est
toujours la même chose
moi je pense que la question de
l'intervention de l'union européenne
dans l'énergie en france pour soutenir
eux que l'on revienne à des énergies qui
font exploser
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre je
considère que c'est pas juste
et vous savez que je me suis exprimé sur
ce point
dans le cadre du plan donc c'est
quelqu'un qui à son âge des jeunes donc
de l'énergie une puissance de travail
que je crois personne ne peut nier et
une conscience une conscience en héros
pendant un temps mais ce n'est pas ça ce
n'est pas la 426
vous demandez en gros si à travers son
action il n'a pas réussi à faire baisser
les intentions de vote pour le
rassemblement national alors qu'il est
très clair que pour lui comme pour son
gouvernement
c'est un site et un de ses combats c'est
un des objectifs est est ce que de ce
point de vue là c'est raté
dans ce ca n'est pas rater pour le
gouvernement ou pas seulement pour le
gouvernement c'est raté pour toutes les
forces qu'on dit républicaine en tout
cas pour tous ceux qui n'appartiennent
pas aux extrêmes parce que c'est eux
c'est c'est l'ensemble de la vie
politique du pays qui précisément
devrait faire reculer les tentations
extrémistes et françois bayrou
je sais que vous pensez que dans l'année
qui est devant nous dernière ligne
droite de la présidentielle société
médiatique tout peut arriver
oui vous considérez que tout peut
arriver est-ce qu'on ferme la porte là
ce matin entre nous à l'idée d'une
candidature de françois bayrou en jeu à
la présidentielle de 2000 22 je vous
voyais venir jeu c'est pas ma manière de
penser
je n'ai jamais fermé la porte à rien
voilà dans ma vie à rien et jeux et j'en
ai fait la preuve c'est pas ça la
question
on est devant une situation plus grave
que notre pays n'en a jamais rencontré
pour des raisons planétaire
l'environnement le virus et pour des
raisons internes nationale la france est
dans une situation où elle a perdu son
ce sa capacité par exemple notre
appareil de production est en crise
profonde industrielles agricoles
c'est l'objet devant un commissariat de
service on a reculé
or nous sommes un pays qui est
entièrement construit autour du contrat
social le pays le plus généreux en aide
sociale de la planète et ce contrat
social est insoutenable si nous ne
construisons pas tout ça donc si j'ai
bien suivi vous fermez pas la porte pour
reconnaît leur est tellement grave que
je veux absolument est indiscutablement
en soutien de toute entreprise de
reconquête et de reconstruction et c'est
évidemment le président de la république
qui est le mieux placé aujourd'hui pas
seulement parce qu'il est en place mais
parce qu'il est ce qu'il est et que
personne je ne vois absolument personne
qui puisse être sérieusement envisagée
dans les circonstances nous sommes dans
l'opposition pour pour assumer ses
fonctions
merci françois bayrou d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce midi david edwige
alors on se revoit vite tout de suite
c'est film godin dominique rizet affaire
suivante je vous retrouve à 18h pour bfm
tv